♪♪
Snow:
Parisian couture...
[camera flash]
Snow:
...could influence how thousands of
ordinary women...
dream and live.
Snow:
But fashion needs a new leader.
A figurehead.
Woman:
Monsieur Dior.
[cheering]
SNOW:
I keep looking for the great collection-
[camera flash]
SNOW:
-to rise from the ashes of the war.
["Haute" by Janelle Monáe plays]
Monsieur Dior, what do you desire?
Dior:
To design the most beautiful
women's clothing that ever existed.
♪ They say I look haute ♪
Christian Dior ruined French couture.
Coco:
And I'm coming back to save it.
[mimics perfume]
Dior:
For those of us who lived
through the chaos of war,
creation was survival.
Elsa:
The legend of Coco Chanel.
If people only knew.
♪ If I keep on givin' 'em
looks that can kill ♪
♪ They gon' have to come and arrest me ♪
Chanel can be very treacherous.
Oh yes.
["My Heart is Full" by Norah Jones plays]
Are you happy with
the revolution you started?
♪ Eyes are wide ♪
Dior:
There is the truth,
♪ My mind is free ♪
but there is always another
truth that lives behind it.
Your sister, she's not safe.
Lucien:
Creation cannot stop the bullets.
But creation is our way forward.
Our choices matter.
♪ I am standing ♪
♪ Use my arms ♪
♪ Use my legs ♪
♪ Use my hands ♪
♪ Use my heart ♪
Devin:
Your house will be magnificent.
♪ Use my voice ♪
You think Dior is fashion?
♪ I will rise ♪
Real talent is turning your
life into something bigger.
♪ I will rise ♪
People need to feel.
Dior:
Dream.
They need to live again.
Dior:
We can create a new world for them.
♪♪